how's it going guys my name is Matt you
are watching code Tech and tutorials
this is the third unreal tutorial about
making a first person character and
we're gonna pick up right where we left
off from the previous video so if you're
not sure where we are it might be a good
idea to start from the beginning of this
series and go through but basically we
are getting all the basics of a FPS
character going so what we want to do
now at this point is have some sort of
way for the game to actually end because
right now we can just hit play and oh
god I gotta get rid of this background
sound please know it sounds like birds
or something there's obviously no birds
anywhere let's not do that so I'm just
going to delete it for the time being
and hit play again and now there's no
background sound to annoy us so health
bar looks good we can move around we can
jump we got a little huh sound and we
can just there's nothing really to do
sure we can fall off the world but even
then I think eventually we die there's
no real way to have much interaction
with the game so what we're gonna do is
make something happen when we go below
zero hit points and maybe add some ways
to take damage and I'm going to show you
how to build all that and all that stuff
so the first thing we want to do is go
to our main BP FPS character that we've
been working with and open it up let's
put it up here so we have a nice tab and
we want some more event ticks so
currently we have one event tick we're
just reaching regenerate some HP and we
went over that last video so for this
video we're gonna have a new thing on
the event ticket we basically want to
check and see if we're dead so we go
ahead and move this out of the way
because we're gonna need a bit more
space uh yeah that's fine so I'm gonna
drag this event tick actually out of the
HP regen and drag this whatever it's
called the pathing and we're gonna do a
sequence so a sequence there it is flow
control sequence basically a sequence
allows you to do multiple things so
first thing we want to check
we want to do the HP regen and then
second thing we're going to now do a
check of dead type of method so we're
gonna do an if branch here and let me
take a look
basically we want to see if our current
HP is less than zero so the condition is
going to be exactly that so we'll grab
our current HP and we're gonna do and a
less than check float less than so if HP
is less than zero hold on it should be
less than equal to because you could
still survive at zero hit points if it's
just less than so we don't want less
than equal to zero so if your current HP
is zero or less the condition we're
going to go to is our this is going to
be true and so our true setting here is
going to be a basically a quick game
quit game and this is really enough to
take care of it however we need a
specific player so a specific player a
specific player to quit the game if not
specified player zero will quit so if
this might work fine on our own
since we are player zero but in general
you want this to map to whoever you want
to quit the game because multiplayer and
all that so we're gonna get get player
controller and that is the specific
player of our player
now if our HP goes below zero it just
immediately quits that's at least
something however we're going to make a
few improvements here
now I won't be later the big thing I
need here is a way to actually take
damage because there's no way in this
game for me to currently lose hit points
so going back to the level editor let's
add in a way to hit to lose hit points
so we're gonna use a let's use a sphere
trigger and just drag that sphere
trigger in here move it in so when you
walk over this it you can do stuff
basically who's all this trigger is I'm
gonna increase it in size a little and
there's nothing here to really for us to
be able to see what's going on so we
can't tell even the trigger box is there
it's non-existent you can't even tell
when you walk over it so let's add some
effects so that you can tell so going
back to our trigger sphere we can okay
we can go into starter content and grab
a particle emitter so we'll make this
maybe we'll make it some fire so we're
gonna drag fire actually as a child of
this trigger sphere so I want to drag it
in here relative a close but then over
here and our whatever you call this
world out outliner I'm going to make it
a child of the trigger sphere and you
can tell it's a child now so that way
when we move our trigger sphere it moves
the fire along with it and they just
kind of stay together now the fire is
really just from looks so we can so we
can actually tell where this is so now
when we hit play when you see the fire
there and what we can do is we can make
it so that when we walk on the fire we
take some damage over time until we
leave it well that's pretty standard for
like walking over a campfire or
something in a game take a little bit of
damage to your feet and okay so now we
got to go to this trigger sphere and
just build in some damage we could also
put this on the character I think but it
makes more sense to put it on the object
since it's coming from the object so
what we're gonna do is just so what you
have to do is you have to select this
trigger sphere right click on it it's
going to select
fire instead because I don't know
because that's how it is so what we have
to do is hide the fire select the sphere
again and then right-click and it
actually lets us right click on the
trigger sphere actually I don't think it
did I'm pretty sure it selected the
floor okay so I figured out it's
actually kind of easy to click on this
you just have to right click on the
button click on the button I was trying
to click on the arrows before and that
seems to select the thing behind it but
if you click on this little button of
the trigger and right click on that you
can easily get to this menu so I stand
corrected all right so now that I've
right clicked it I get this context menu
and you can go to add event and you can
have it do different things based on
events happening now these events are
from the level blueprint so what I want
to do is is make a actor begin overlap
so it brings us into the blueprint of
our level for this and it says on actor
begin overlap the trigger sphere were
working on so on begin overlap we're
going to have to add a few variables
over here now there might be a better
way of organizing it but I'm just gonna
kind of do it in a way that gets it done
and maybe we'll straighten it later if
we need to we want to add some variables
because we want this to be a damage over
time effect this begin overlap only
triggers once when you enter it so we
actually need a couple different
triggers so we need one for when you
enter it we want to start taking damage
and we want to leave it we want to stop
taking damage so then we we need a end
overlap on actor and overlap and I don't
see that anywhere easily here add event
trigger okay here we go
it's probably under this and event
trigger for sphere 1 add on actor end
overlap so there we go we have both of
those and now we just need to to work
with a variable so we'll have a boolean
of
in fire so if they are noted as being in
the fire then they'll be taking some
damage so when I hit compile just so
that I can make sure this is false okay
so this iniciative initializes to false
that's that's great so when it begins
when we begin the overlap we want to you
set in fire to true we'll just check
this box to make it true and when we
leave it we want to set the effect that
we're in fire to false so that will take
care of it however this also means the
actor that's overlapping for the trigger
so that's just our normal character but
we have to do a cast to our FPS
character to make sure so really this
ends up being let's see overlapped actor
okay we need to bring this little chain
through it so it's got to check that
first and the other actor is the thing
that's overlapping with the sphere so
overlapped actor is the sphere other
actor is our player or whatever is
overlapping and we only want to do this
fire thing if our character overlaps
with a bit something else we're not
worried about that so they were good
there we go so we have a cast failed
option and some other stuff we're not
going to use those we just want to set
this in fire to true because the damage
is going to come from this fire so on
the end overlap is very similar we're
also going to do a cast make sure it's
the character that's leaving and if so
and we set our end fire to false in this
check mark of course is the true or
false this one's true this one's false
so that should that should toggle are in
fire but now we need an event trigger on
this thing
let's see I don't even see that let's
see what was a cold event tick okay
event tick there we go so we're gonna
add an event tick and this is just in
general on the world so if it were
detected as being in the world and in
fire we're gonna take some fire damage
so this damage it's gonna happen so we
need to do some checks here and also of
course it's just going to reduce health
every single tick which could be like
100 and however many frames were getting
per second so we could get a good
zillion ticks per second so we want to
slow that down with a bit of cooldown on
the tick and we're gonna do that very
similarly to how we did the cooldown on
the last video so what we need here is
we need a let's see we need a damage
tick
I guess we'll call it I don't know or
what I call the last one I guess we'll
call it the damage tick cool down and
this is gonna be a float and we're gonna
make yet another variable called damage
tick accumulator a CC for short I'm
gonna take the cool down off with it man
oh that's fine I like cool down being
there CD that helps me okay so I'm gonna
hit compile so I can set some default
values this event tick default value is
just going to be every let's see what
should we take damage every one second
every two seconds I feel like - I feel
like everyone seconds good and we'll
make sure that's false to zero it does
okay so what we're gonna do here is when
I have an if branch so on every every
loop we're gonna check if the condition
of in fire is true in fire so if on any
event tick if we're in fire we are going
to see if it's been long enough for us
to take damage so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to set our
damage ticket accumulator
and that is just going to increase by
our Delta that's passed since the last
tic and so of course we'll need the
current damage tic accumulation number
which is to get so whatever it currently
is plus the Delta seconds and that is
going to increment the damage tic
accumulator by however much time has
passed so now what we want to do is we
want to go here and make another
condition and another if condition and
we want to see if the damage tic
accumulation time is greater than the
cooldown so let's go ahead and get the
cool down there just to cool down so if
we can you know there's are many ways to
write this you can you can reverb kind
of doing some reverse logic here
compared to how I usually do it but
basically if the damage to cool down is
less than the accumulated time here then
the condition is true and we should be
taking some damage so we'll just do some
damage we want to make sure it's a
player that is taking damage so we're
going to do a cast to be p FPS character
again and then we're just gonna get the
player character that way it's working
with the person who is running around
like player index 0 that's us so that's
something we might have to revisit if we
go into multiplayer type stuff but
basically we want to just reduce by fire
damage so let's make a little variable
called just fire damage tick
okay yeah that's fine I guess so a bit
of a confusing set of variable names
there maybe I can make them a little
better but that's fine we can basically
set this to what we want our fire damage
to be maybe we want to take five damage
let's just do a five for now and what
we're gonna do is if this cast was
successful we're going to set our
current HP and there it is and of course
the target is going to be this BP
character and the new damage well the
new hitpoints is going to be five less
so we got to get our current get current
HP just dragging off that node getting
our current HP and we're gonna - it by
the fire damage tick there it is and
that new number is now going to equal
our current HP okay that's good enough
for now we could play like a sound of
something burning or a sound of our
character making some so noise but boy
we'll just we'll skip that for now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna set our
damage timer or set our damage tick
accumulator back to zero once we've
taken damage because we want to reset
that cooldown so now we don't need to
drag the current HP into that just set
it to zero zero is already there we're
good so now what should happen is if
we're in that fire or the trigger sphere
well the world will set us to on fire
and we'll start taking damage and once
we leave it it'll make us not on fire
anymore and we will stop taking damage
so there's no catching on fire or
anything like that just go ahead and
compile all these save all these and hit
play and now if we walk over here I'm
gonna wait for a second for that little
thing in the top-left to disappear there
we go we walk over here we should start
taking some damage and there it is it is
chunking us down significantly and once
we get to zero that death should
and we should just quit don't quit we're
no longer playing all right very good so
it's more obvious the quit is a little
more obvious if you do a standalone game
simulation because that way it's
actually a full window here you know it
looks like it tabbed out of it okay let
me so here we go there we go so go over
here in the fire taking some damage now
you can only tell because of the meter
and it doesn't stop our region so we
still have a region tick every once in a
while but it's not enough to save us
through fire damage okay so the quit
works fine now there's not a whole lot
of feedback about what's happening we
just you know so we're gonna need some
sounds in here so the player kind of has
some sense that something is going wrong
other than their health bar moving so
once again we're gonna open audacity and
we're just gonna have a little fun with
this and we're gonna play a burning
sound and we're gonna play a death sound
so for our burning sound let's see uh uh
uh that should be good okay so we'll
just select that now and we're gonna go
to file export selected audio and yep
this is the area in our project where we
save the previous one so it's already
mapped there and we're just going to I
don't know what kind of a st. a sound
that was maybe like with three HS uh-huh
okay 16-bit wave that's fine for now and
it clear the saved values there it's
just me working on it and looks like
unreal smart enough to detect a new file
we'll hit import and now we have that so
we can just drag off of this what we can
do I guess we can do it at the very end
after the damage tick accumulation is
set back to zero Blues hit a play sound
right at the end here play sound that
location and of course we're gonna
select the asset here
which will be the sound so let's go
ahead and test that out we're gonna hit
play save selected and it's gonna play
right at our location - right where
we're taking the damage so now we should
get some sound feedback okay cool
alright so that seems to work great
I think another well I was just thinking
I could add a little more logic in here
because once we get to dying the sounds
aren't going to always play as expected
when when we die if it you know if it's
triggering something else but I'm not
gonna worry about that just let's go and
do one other thing we want to have a bit
of a notification when we quit sure the
window closes but that doesn't really
tell the player anything they'll sure a
little know by this point that they quit
because they ran out of HP but we can
make this just a little bit better not a
lot better but just just some minor
improvements here and basically what we
want to do is drag this over a little
bit and do a few things before we quit
like let's make a death sound effect and
also let's give it a little delay that
way it doesn't quit immediately and
gives it a little time to play out maybe
our final animation final sounds before
it quits so we've already got if they're
below zero do something and what we want
to do is well if we're gonna have a
delay we're going to need to keep a
boolean of whether we are alive or not
and this is gonna come in handy in a
couple different areas but for now it's
just going to be boolean that is called
is alive so the first thing we're gonna
do is when we branch off of this is we
want to check if we are alive so we're
gonna do yet another if and we're gonna
check the condition of alive
it is alive so if they are alive we will
continue on - well first of all we're
gonna set
is alive to false so unchecked there
that's good so if we're alive and we go
below zero it sets us to dead and what
that'll do is it won't keep doing this
every tick when we're already dead
because it's just gonna set us to dead
and then continue on with the rest and
if this triggers again before it gets
too quick game it won't keep retrying
the quick game and this other thing
we're gonna do because we are going to
do a play sound at location and the
sound we want to be a death sound let's
go ahead and open audacity again I'll
close that track and let's do another
one hold on me come up with a death
sound close enough right all right so
we'll go we'll just select that and do
what we did last time file export export
selected audio and another sound 3.h is
okay just some basic grunt type sounds
so yeah very good
and that exported and we see it here
with unreal because unreal is is van ass
and we're gonna just select it in our
asset now we should see it here there it
is
so now we'll play that but the thing is
is it's gonna quit the game right away
so we're not even really gonna hear our
sound because the game is going to quit
so we need to put a delay right here and
this is the whole point of the is a live
thing too so we don't spam this during
the delay so we will just want to do a
delay probably about a 1 1.2 seconds is
probably good of a delay and then we'll
quit let's make it a little bit longer
like the 1.3 and I think that'll take it
that'll do fine and since we have this
yeah it's not gonna spam this sound of
uh it's just going to play it once
during this delay before the quit all
right so this is the kind of hacky but
it should get the job done
let's go see if it works
I'll hit compile save whatever play and
let's just go right over here into the
fire and start taking some damage and as
you can see we're not actually dying so
something's bugged out so why is it not
quitting on us I must have something
bugged here oh I know what it is this is
alive is defaulting to false it's never
true so that's why it's not ever going
to this true case so we need to default
this is a live value to true by just
checking it there and hit compile and
now that should solve our problem
because we were just never going down
this branch what they'd always mean
false ok very good
so let's go over here now and see if it
works ok very good we got our final
sound but also there's just one little
last bug and that's that it keeps
playing this play sound at location if
we're already dead so we could put a
last little if statement in here and
just check our current 8 yeah let's do
and is alive so we are looking for is
alive but also we need to make sure we
get it from the player so it'd be this
cast right here is live alive so if they
are alive we'll continue with the damage
if not this doesn't work anymore but
also as we know if they are triggered as
dead we're gonna be doing something else
so these two blueprints are kind of
working together with their combined
logic and hopefully it makes sense now
let's go ahead and get beat up very good
very good so we didn't keep playing the
damage tick sound after we died and that
given a didn't work with the delay only
play the other sound work I think we're
good was tested again
okay yeah that seems to be working
pretty well so that's it that's how we
get to an in-state take some damage a
little damage over time tick and some
more sounds I hope you enjoyed this
tutorial and maybe learn some things
last thing I'm gonna do one talk of my
outro is just leave some comments thank
you guys so much for watching I hope
that you're all doing well this can be
during this trying time in the world and
you know that was a great time to be
learning development take damage if
alive and on fire and I think these are
fairly obvious start start burning yep
and this one just basically stopped
burning so there we go I think we just
got to make one more a little comment
over here on our new setup here of
basically quitting the game and dying
quit game after a short delay if below
zero HP so there we go
and things are looking pretty well now I
think let me know if you have any
questions don't forget to Like and
subscribe it really does help me a lot
of same with comments so I'd appreciate
any any feedback any comments anything
you want to say is fine show me your
projects alright peace out guys see in
the next video